can you take that off now we've had fun
with the costumes please
it's bothering me can you take this off
what are you he wore that to
what are you in full regalia here he got
excited about the
costume the love of god my culture is
not your costume
don't disrespect the mayans who used to
sacrifice children on a mountain
the minds didn't dress like that i know
what's going on folks
i'm incredibly intelligent many people
are shocked
by that i i used to i remember eighth
grade i
i said this is the time to be cool there
are times in your life when you should
be cool
many of you have never been cool how sad
is that
being cool is destroying property like
antifa
if if i was a kid right now i'd be in
antifa because it's cool
that's what i'd be you know
i'd be in i'd be in a like fat antifa
which is the saddest antifa where it's
like you're
you're like heavily breathing everybody
else is really getting in the riding
you're kind of in the back
you know you just have a lot of fun
things to say about karl marx but like
dude you weren't even there you're like
oh
i was there dude you didn't even do
anything we all got arrested
you didn't even run up the hill you sat
down
you sat down in all black no
i would provide the intellectual fire
me and ray comp are going to do a great
sketch called fat antifa
where it's two guys that were on their
way to charlottesville to fight
the right-wing people but they kept
getting distracted by
fast food restaurants and then
and they kept eating and then eventually
they were just beaten to a bloody pulp
by a female trump supporter
in like a golden corral parking lot we
never did it
but i remembered 8th grade it was like
it's time to be cool so the cool guys at
my school they had names like johnny and
alfred
we went to [ __ ] be cool and throw
eggs and hang out in the park and
shaving cream things
and that was cool and i wish that for
all of you i hope you have a journey
that involves a
night like that where you can be cool
and hang out with people like johnny and
alfred and
throw eggs and do shaving cream and then
i went to my i
after that night i went at the end of
that night when my dad was eating dinner
at a steakhouse the steakhouse in the
town i grew up in and i came
and i smelled like shaving cream but i
said it was cologne
and my father's friend who owned the
steakhouse was like ah you got the
cologne on for the girls i was like yep
that's exactly right that's exactly
right little do you know i've been
sucking dick in the bushes
i was not i was not i was not doing that
i was throwing eggs and doing shaving
cream so i i hope there's a way for
kids to vandalize safely
you can't even be against vandalism
anymore as long as you just say well
it's uh it's political
right political so if you're a kid
and you're leaving your house with two
dozen eggs
and your parents go what are you doing
you turn around and say
shut up you capitalist pig and shut the
door
they can't say [ __ ] to you be like oh
what am i doing uh it's
called a revolution how about you
keep watching how i met your mother okay
and yes i will have leftovers leave them
in the fridge
but i'm gonna do out go out and do
revolution with my friends
be with my friends so much of this sad
shitty life we all live is social once
you realize that you realize that
there's
there's no hope and ideas everybody
wants to just get hugged
there's no hope and ideas dummy
i'm going out with my friends to burn
down the courthouse
i have friends too it's a [ __ ] suit
everybody's a [ __ ] social these maga
hat [ __ ] since
they're driving around in cadillac see
you know they're are you on the team i'm
on a team we got something to do
so much of this pitiful miserable
experience of life
is just finding people to [ __ ] and
tolerate you
that's it this this is all
thing i remember that you don't get
smarter than when you're in eighth grade
and you go i want to throw eggs with the
cool cake you're just
everybody wants to throw eggs with the
cool kids you just want to get invited
you want to have value you want to have
worth shut up
stop being bigger and better than
everything you just want to shave and
cream someone's car with johnny and
alfred
that's what you want to do now whatever
that version of that is
playing golf and having a 401k who cares
same [ __ ] it's all social we're social
creatures nobody's really an island
some people very few the majority of us
are
organisms that need others in validation
constantly and